un ultime recours c'est ce que tente la
famille de rémy fraysse en ayant formé
un pourvoi en cassation
depuis le 16 février dernier la plus
haute juridiction française examine ce
recours pour bien comprendre un retour
en arrière s'impose
nous sommes le 26 octobre 2014 le corps
de rémy fraysse jeunes botanistes de 21
ans et militant écologiste est retrouvé
sur le chantier du barrage de siemens
dans le tarn
une découverte qui fait suite à des
affrontements entre les forces de
l'ordre et des opposants à la
construction du barrage le site du
chantier fait à l'époque transformé en
zad peu après le décès du jeune homme
des traces de tnt sont retrouvés sur le
site et les grenades au ffa autorisées à
l'époque des faits est utilisée le jour
des heures par les forces de l'ordre
sont pointés du doigt l'une d'entre
elles aurait causé la mort de rémy
fraysse le 29 octobre 2014
une information judiciaire contre x est
ouverte pour je cite violences
volontaires ayant entraîné la mort sans
intention de la donner
plus tard le gendarme soupçonné d'être
l'auteur du tir de la grenade est placé
en garde à vue
mais finalement en mars 2016 ce dernier
est placé sous le statut de témoin
assisté
un non lieu sera ensuite prononcés en sa
faveur en janvier 2018 un verdict
confirmé deux ans plus tard par la cour
d'appel de toulouse
pour les juges le tir de grenade était
strictement nécessaires et
proportionnées
il n'y a rien reprocher aux gendarmes
dont l'attitude a été exemplaire
les gendarmes devaient se défendre ils
n'ont fait que respecter la loi
mais pour la défense de la famille de
rémy fraises c'est tout le contraire
il y as suffisamment d'indicés graves et
concordants dans le dossier pour
considérer que le gendarme qui a lancé
la grenade a commis des violences
volontaires
on considère notamment que les
conditions n'étaient pas réunies pour
utiliser une grenades paralysantes aux
f1 une arme militaire extrêmement
dangereuse d'autre part les avocats
estiment que la grenade coincé entre la
veste du jeune homme et son sac à dos
avant d'exploser
après avoir été tirée en cloche et non
au sol a été choisie je cite faute de
mieux par les militaires pour la défense
du gendarme incriminé
il y à 97 % de chances que le non-lieu
soit confirmée en cassation
dans ce cas la famille de rémy fraysse
elle souhaite porter le dossier devant
la cour européenne des droits de l'homme
depuis le décès du jeune militant des
rassemblements sont organisés chaque
année à siemens en sa mémoire mais aussi
pour dénoncer de manière générale les
violences policières et luzarches des
armes dans le cadre du maintien de
l'ordre